opening of Gilcrease orchards here in
the valley it's a sure sign of spring
but as a small business is certainly
feeling the impact of the corona virus
pandemic via Holman live now at
Gilcrease orchard with how they're
keeping people safe there during this
time - morning Bianca looks beautiful
out there
hey all yes it's a beautiful sight out
here at the orchard and so as you many
may know this orchard was supposed to
open last month but with things maturing
and the heat is steaming up a lot more
there are winter veggies like these snow
peas that are ready to be harvested
every turning a lot faster than expected
and they're ready for you and your
family to come and pick it won't be long
till these 60 acres are filled with
fruits like apricots and things like
squash but the winter crops they hate
the heat so to reduce so they're ready
to be harvest also to reduce the threat
of Cova 19 exposure the orchard has
announced new rules regarding food
handling if you plan to get any leafy
greens you got to bring your own
scissors and of course you can only pick
what you plan to buy and take with you
and also since lasting opening last
Thursday director Mark Rubin he shares
an update with us the crops were ready
the carrots are beautiful right now and
the beets are ready so everything's
ready to go and if it gets hot then
we'll lose a lot of stuff they've been
good it's been steady a lot of people
are just happy to be outside and have
some outdoor activity to do
and I hear their hours of operations
Tuesday Thursday and Saturday from 7:00
to noon as you plan to pick you have to
of course bring your own gloves and mask
okay and they are encouraging social
distancing of course they have lots of
space for people to spread out and then
again with it heating up now recently
some of their other things like the
apricots they should be ready pretty
soon and of course if you love jams and
jellies you'll definitely want to come
out here and support this local business
reporting live Bianca Holman 8 News now